[Music]
welcome to the Macmillan report I'm
Marilyn Wilkes your host and our guest
is Thomas Thurston who is the director
of education and public outreach at the
Gilder Lehrman Center for the Study of
slavery and abolition at the Macmillan
Center he has organized several
collaborative international institutes
for teachers in Ghana the United States
and to the UK today we'll talk with Tom
about the recent workshop series he
developed called teaching transatlantic
histories models for collaboration
between US and African teachers and
classrooms welcome Tom thanks Marilyn
it's great to be here
let's begin with an overview of the
workshops sure tell us about them well
we have ten teachers from the
Connecticut greater New Haven area
attend from Johannesburg South Africa
and ten from Sierra Leone who are
working together in teams I have 20
teachers in Connecticut half that group
is working with 10 teachers in Sierra
Leone the other half is working with 10
teachers in in South Africa part of it
involves traveling to each other's
countries so we just returned from
Johannesburg in in in June where we met
with our teachers there and we're
planning a trip to December but most of
it is building classroom to classroom
collaborative learning opportunities so
part of the reason for the travel is to
get the teachers a chance to learn more
about each other's countries histories
to get to know each other to visit
classrooms when possible all those sort
of things I am curious about how the
teachers were chosen did you can pick
them what was the process no I did I
wanted to avoid hand picking because
then I'd obviously I have my face
sorry here in Connecticut I I contact
contacted a lot of educators in the
state someone from the Department of
Education from and from the Connecticut
Council for the social studies from the
New Haven Public Schools and I asked
them to give me a group a list of
teachers who they considered their top
teachers I didn't want to do to
broadcast a kind of call for
applications because that just could
have been overwhelmed oh sure and I did
a similar thing in in in both South
Africa and in Sierra Leone where I had
people associated with school of
education at Vic's Waters rond in
Johannesburg and someone at at the
University of Sierra Leone who was like
a history educator kind of picked
teachers that they'd worked with and
that they respected and and it's all hot
to say it's been great choices all
around all the teachers are just amazing
teachers have all of the teachers been
together at one point because I the two
countries in Africa have all of the
teachers met with the teachers from the
United States just the just the group
from from a Johannesburg
we you know we went out there and had a
had a 10 day workshop out there so that
was their first opportunity to meet in
person but the group the u.s. teachers
and Sierra Leoneans they've connected
via whatsapp and so they've got to know
each other they've shared photos they've
talked about classroom projects but
December December early January will be
their first chance to kind of meet face
to face when we go and visit Sierra
Leone okay so that's later just just a
couple yeah we've kind of staggered are
the two groups just - okay that's
exciting to head back and yeah I am
curious to know how what was the impetus
behind developing this workshop series
sure well as you mentioned we did
something similar back in
inglis 2009 we began it was a three year
program with teachers from Ghana the
United States and the UK and the focus
of that three year series was on the
transatlantic slave trade but we focused
the kind of education around it by
country so we we started in Ghana and we
had teachers professors who were leading
the workshop from both the UK the United
States and Ghana who co-taught it and
then the second year we did it here at U
Young University and brought you know
brought the groups there and the third
we finished at New York in the UK and
part of them and we wanted to make sure
that this wasn't just an opportunity for
Americans or Brits to visit Africa and
to to have this great kind of experience
we wanted that to be reciprocal both and
so we made a point to make sure that
that that all that the groups were
always invited there was always a
tripartite group of teachers in the same
with the with the education we didn't
want it to be say just an American
professor just just a UK professor we
wanted to have professors who were
speaking at the workshop organizing
workshop that represented all three
countries that was important to how we
did it so that was kind of impetus and
and of course in a lot of ways is a
great success but what I felt was
lacking was anything built into the
program to make it sustainable to give
to really encourage teachers to continue
to collaborate with one another all
these were kind of site based workshops
where they a lot of learning happened
and a lot of friendships were made but
there wasn't anything happening between
classrooms and it was earlier on a
little harder to do that but also we
hadn't built it into the program and
despite that a lot of the especially
American and Ghanaian teachers they did
that anyway and to this day I last
summer I heard from a from a teacher
down in the DC area who was
going out to Ghana and he was staying
with a friend there you know that he'd
met in the workshop and they're
continuing him and others are continuing
to collaborate between classrooms so I
really wanted to make collaboration the
focus of this new series of
international workshops okay and in the
workshops the teachers are creating
curriculum what exactly is the goal of
the workshop for the teachers well part
of the goal of the workshop is to
familiarize themselves selves with the
with the various histories of the
country so in in Johannesburg we really
focused on on apartheid its origins it's
it's the end of apartheid and and
legacies and so it's both the Americans
and the teachers from Johannesburg who
were sharing this we did it at the
apartheid museum in Johannesburg so we
wanted them to get a sense of that
history so they all kind of came with
that and in Sierra Leone it's going to
be a history of the nation of Sierra
Leone but with special emphasis on the
connections with the United States in
particular here in New Haven New Haven
and Freetown Sierra Leone our sister
cities and I yeah that the Amistad
memorial that's in front of City Hall
that's those captives were Mende people
from what's now Sierra Leone and and
they know about that history probably as
much as or better than students here in
the United States sink sink a bay whose
was a leader of the captives his
portrait is at the New Haven Historical
Society he's on the 5000 Leone a note
there and everyone knows that story so I
can hold up a picture of postcard of him
that I brought from from our museum here
and asked us anyone know who this is to
a classroom of of young students they
all know I don't I hope the same would
go here in New Haven but I'm not quite
sure all right
did you notice particularly since you
have completed the workshop in
Johannesburg when the teachers from the
United States worked with the teachers
from Johannesburg were there any
differences in perspective in terms of
the history
did you know were there any surprises
that that you noticed that's an
interesting question I think what
surprised me was how engaged the
teachers in Johannesburg were with what
you would expect to be a kind of history
they already knew and they were you know
they do know that history it's it's
something that as history teachers they
that's a part of their curriculum but
there's it just reminded me that there's
always something new to hear about it we
had our professor here at Yale
University Dan Magaziner came and and so
he was able to kind of you know bring
his perspective but then we had
professors from Johannesburg and and and
former activists and and and others who
were also adding perspectives that in
some ways I think that because it
matters more to teachers in Johannesburg
they were probably more engaged in
conversation in questions than the
Americans were I think and it's not
surprising but but we as Americans it's
very easy it's understandable it's
almost what you expect to happen but we
always hear that history of apartheid
and want to relate it with Jim Crow and
civil rights movement that which is all
very well and good but you also have to
remember that that's a history in and of
itself that is not you know important
because of its semblance to what happens
here and so you're they're high school
teachers is that correct
yeah there are a mix next year we have
we have even we have even some
elementary school teachers so it's a
challenge to to work with them but it's
a mixture of teachers all with a focus
on history
okay and then moving forward what do you
hope comes out of the workshops
ultimately well what I want to see is is
is them develop classroom activities
that can be shared so the the group in
from the South Africa Connecticut group
are a little further along they've met
each other and they're already
developing curriculum most of which is
centered around either for the younger
students cultural aspects like music
dance some people are looking at
literature and sharing literature to
work and then many are talking about you
know a comparative study of the civil
rights movement here in the states and
in the anti-apartheid movement and civil
rights in fact is a subject of study in
South Africa it's important they see it
as important to understanding their
history as well so already we have some
fairly well-developed projects are going
on a number of teachers are focusing on
the role that young people played in
both the civil rights and anti-apartheid
struggle but also in contemporary and
rights-based struggle both in South
Africa and in the States so in a couple
weeks we're going to be presenting some
of our preliminary projects at the
Connecticut Council for the social
studies really yeah I'm very I'm very
impressed I was surprised that that my
Connecticut teachers were were to the
point where they said oh yeah we really
want I'd suggest it if you want you
think and they were all out of ten I
think seven of them are going to be
attending yeah I'm very emphasizing so
I'm very impressed
so the curriculum or curricula that they
have developed is that going to be
accessible to you know through the
website and everyone you know basically
in the world can access it and use it if
they'd like yeah I that that certainly
is one of the goals is it that you know
part of it is goes to this
sustainability but also how to
disseminate how to spread this so some
of it will be making resources and
curricula available online and some of
the way that we want to sustain and
disseminate is to encourage partnerships
beyond that original group so that and
usually what I imagine is is instead of
teacher to teacher thinking of as a
school to school partnership so that so
that other teachers either in social
studies or perhaps like you know English
literature or maybe even math and
science that they're interested they
they want to develop relationships so
that we have a stronger stronger
relationships in some ways there's kind
of an institutional relationship between
schools which is I think easier to
maintain than a person-to-person
relation someone moves and retires that
sort of thing okay well we will look for
those materials on the Gilder Lehrman
Center's website and the product the
project sounds very innovative and
exciting so thank you for being here
with us today and sharing it well thanks
it was my pleasure
okay for more information about Tom and
the Gilder Lehrman Center please visit
our website at macmillan report yale.edu
be sure to join us again for another
episode of the Macmillan report made
possible through funding from the
Whitney and Betty Macmillan Center for
International and area studies at you
you